le grand besançon s'est engagé à réduire
ses dépenses selon l'objectif fixé par
le gouvernement une mesure de
restriction qui doit permettre une
économie de 13 milliards d'euros à
l'échelle de tout le pays d'ici 2022
une chasse aux dépenses accepté sans
rechigner par le premier des bisontins
regarde partout un sou est un sou un
euro est un euro
par exemple nous utilisons beaucoup de
services et les services qui deviennent
communs entre la ville de besançon le
grand besançon et donc à terme il y aura
des économies de matière de masse
salariale sans forcément diminué il ne
faut absolument pas ce d'ailleurs sans
diminuer effectivement la qualité du
service public
réduire les dépenses jusqu'à supprimer à
terme une partie des emplois du grand
besançon mais sans transiger sur la
qualité du service
un défi assumer précisant ça ne touche
que le fonctionnement
cela touche pas l'investissement on va
continuer à investir des dizaines de
millions dans les années à venir pour
effectivement faire en sorte que le
grand besançon reste à la hauteur de ce
qu'il est à savoir pour les équilibres
metropolitan pour cet élu opposants à la
politique d' emmanuel macron le contrat
vient surenchérir la politique
d'austérité menée par le gouvernement
en empêchant les collectivités de jouer
pleinement leur rôle démocratique au
plus près de leurs administrés on va
créer une bibliothèque d'agglomération
avec une bibliothèque universitaire on
aura peut-être l'argent pour pouvoir
mener l'investissement sauf que dedans
on pourra pas la faire fonctionner je
pense que c'est une atteinte à la
république à l'esprit républicain qu'on
pouvoir ou de masse et puis les
collectivités qui décideront de leur
propre avenir
un encadrement des dépenses strictes qui
concerne comme pour le grand besançon
322 collectivités du territoire français